merci un peu de sérieux faire la
plasticienne entre metal og aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que cela signifie
et qu'est ce que ça implique être
plasticien c'est travailler dans le
champ des arts plastiques la plastique
c'est la forme la couleur la matière le
son et l'image
mon champ d'expérimentation à moi ça
peut être aussi bien le dessin la
peinture la sculpture la vidéo et la
performance
la performance est quoi et bien c'est
ici et maintenant avec vous car vous
faites partie de mon oeuvre
exemple
exemple avec une photo d'une de mes
performances
intitulé mon ami a le bras long
cette oeuvre peut parler de la question
de la nourriture de la valeur de la
nourriture dans notre société de la
bonne chère et de la malbouffe au sens
matériel comme au sens spirituel pour
vous expliquer le mot entre metal og
je vais isoler le mot entre nez
qu'est-ce que l'entremet au moyen-âge
l'entremet est une pause un petit moment
festif ou politiques lors d'un banquet
pendant lequel les convives
si vous voulez se revigore un petit peu
là papilles avant de replonger encore
dans leurs pas et bien moi c'est pareil
je suis un déclencheur de créativité et
je ferai tout je mettrai tout en oeuvre
pour susciter le désir le désir
d'apprendre le désir de comprendre
l'autre et de comprendre le monde dans
lequel on vit
voilà alors forcément ça engage à quoi
de pratiquer l'encontre mythologie et
bien je me suis toujours interrogé sur
la place de l'artiste dans notre société
et surtout de la question de la
réception d'un art parfois qu'on dit
réservée à une élite
c'est pour ça je me suis engagé et j'ai
pour mission de faire voler en éclats
les clivages de faire tomber les
frontières une à une pour va construire
des ponts pour relier des artistes et
des noms d'artistes et pour créer donc
des liens entre des différents espaces
et différents lieux qu'ils n'auraient
jamais pu se rencontrer sans ça voilà
c'est ça mon métier voilà alors c'est ma
démarche en fait elle est de l'ordre de
la résistance mais de la résistance 12
face à l'uniformisation galopante et au
consensus mou mou le coeur de ma
démarche c'est la transmission
mélanie la transmission avec la
dimension de plaisir parce que il faut
toujours rester aux curieux toujours
préservé notre petite capacité
d'étonnement pour pouvoir partager pour
pouvoir surprendre et pour pouvoir
donner et recevoir comme un cadeau
d'ailleurs le mot cadeau est l'anagramme
du mot audace oui quels sont les outils
pour pratiquer l'entremetteuse logis en
1999 est né arnaud mad art nomade un
centre d'art d'intervention et de
recherche en quoi en entre méthologie en
alors on crée puisqu'il s'agit d'une
équipe et de gens engagés le véhicule
art nomades colporteurs de l'art
contemporain basé on est basée à arnac
la poste arnac la poste
c'est donc une petite commune rurale au
centre de la france c'est important de
le dire car nous rayonnons sur
l'ensemble de la planète à partir d'
arnaque la poste sa forme fait penser
aux véhicules ambulant de nos campagnes
en tout cas en france
et bien c'est normal car il s'agit de se
nourrir pour nourrir à son tour alors
effectivement on peut dire qu'il s'agit
d'une sorte de cheval de troie mais
plutôt très très très bienveillant parce
qu'en fait sa forme commune lui permet
de s'introduire de s'immiscer sur
l'espace public au coeur des foires au
coeur des écoles ou même sur le parvis
des cathédrales et lui permet de
dispenser d
des ateliers d'arts plastiques donc
ouvert à tous et des performances hors
normes
sa forme fait aussi penser un véhicule
pompiers c'est normal parce que c'est de
l'art d'intervention je signale que ce
véhicule est unique en france il a été
fait entièrement sur mesure alors
pompiers oui mais à part qu'il est zébré
de rouge et de vert en fait ça c'est
aussi une stratégie pour mieux se
camoufler dans le paysage son graphisme
est bien fait penser à la fois aux
courbes d'un paysage au parcours qu'on
fait d'un point à un autre d'une idée à
une autre ou alors encore à l'empreinte
d'un doigt a grandi parce que il s'agit
d'art humaniste autres outils dont je
suis l'auteur principal c'est un livre
le livre art nomades se manifeste ou
plutôt je pourrais dire plus tôt c'est
un ovni éditorial il est inclassable
comme mon travail et cet ovni pourquoi
cette envie parce que c'est à la fois un
livre papier traduit en anglais parce
que cette expérience est unique et que
est là pour être but de diffuser
c'est un bloc qui attachés à ce livre
papier c'est aussi des expos et c'est
aussi en plus des conférences
performances
ce livret est utile parce que chacun
peut s'en emparer pour extraire unités
et après la développer et vivre à
nouveau une expérience qui lui soit
propre
c'est ce qui m'intéresse quelles sont
ces expériences quelle est la forme de
ces expériences est gagné n'a pas parce
que hors nomades et inclassable on est
hors normes on est multiforme
parce qu'en fait on est une forme
ouverte et on accueille aussi bien des
artistes professionnels confirmé que des
amateurs que des gens qui passent juste
que par la voie là on est inclassable et
donc c'est ça aussi notre notre notre
richesse c'est cette diversité
d'expressions paul ardenne qui est donc
historien de l'art a même dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de
expérience de ce type ailleurs donc paul
ardenne nuit là le recul et il est assez
pointue dans le domaine de l'art
contemporain
voilà c'est donc de l'art engagé à vous
l'avez compris dollar militants alors
pour vous montrer pour vous montrer les
expériences qui sont complètement unique
alors attention complètement décalé dans
le champ de l'art contemporain on peut
pas mieux faire parce que mon essence
c'est de surprendre les publics de
l'échoppé là où on ne nous attend pas
ici par exemple en premier lieu à ussel
sur le tarmac d'un aéroport
nous avons des officiers de l'armée de
l'air en train de faire des dessins
cochon ce que vous ne voyez pas c'est
qu'il ya 150 gamins handicapés autour
qui bossent aussi pareil après un peu
plus loin nous avons donc une course à
l'escargot mobile alors là c'est en
plein coeur du salon international de
l'agriculture où nous avons mis le feu à
l'équipe on était de vous avec un
philosophe et toubon plus bas ici vous
assistez alors la cité cet été à des
cours de dessin en pédalo à l'eau du lac
de vassivière tant que là on croque est
une oeuvre flottante dont on faisait le
tour ou encore la dernière image t il ya
peu de temps c'était au coeur de l'école
d'art de limoges école dans laquelle je
le travail est donc cette image sous les
synthétise un petit peu là la
philosophie d'art nomade qui mélange à
la fois des artistes confirmés et jeunes
étudiants à la fois donc des gens de la
tribu de ma famille des gens de
l'extérieur d'autres centres d'art et
donc des personnes aussi qui suivent mes
cours publics et un historien de l'art
et là on est en train de procéder une
cérémonie un peu particulière qui
consistait à poser une tâche la tâche du
livre
sur le cac le capot d'une étrange
corvette
voilà moi c'est voilà c'est l'art de
manière ciblée les paradoxes par exemple
enfin j'aime beaucoup le faire côtoyer
plein de choses qui sont différentes
alors parfois avec beaucoup de mal mais
j'espère avec beaucoup de plaisir pour
vous ce soir est par exemple je fais
côtoyé l'art la vie l'espace public
l'espace intime le merveilleux et le
quotidien le vrai le faux le dur le mou
le beau le moche l'inclassable et le
médiocre la désobéissance et l'ordre
établi
la mémoire et le devenir
le toit et le mois alors tout cela
repose sur la prise de risque et we do
qui part qui est bien des artistes des
artistes qui s'engagent à nos côtés et
qui acceptent de travailler avec nous
parce que vous avez compris on travaille
sur l'espace public et donc on peut être
confronté donc son travail
on peut être confrontés et bien à la
critique directe puisqu'on n'est plus à
l'abri dans son atelier et donc on peut
s'exposer aussi pire encore à
l'indifférence des gens ça c'est
terrible ça arrive pas les artistes qui
prennent le risque de travailler avec
nous ils sont ici prennent le risque
aussi de voir leur identité artistique
noyée dans le flot de forme générés par
arnaud made
donc il faut avoir un travail artistique
bien résistant pour pouvoir donc
travailler et partager son travail
ça c'est une des conditions est donc moi
en tant que plasticienne et bien je
prends le risque que mon travail demeure
et enfin de mon travail ne soit jamais
inconnu
ne soit jamais reconnu par mes pairs en
fait et ni par le système
voilà de plus je colporte une un concept
de gentillesse et le caractère
inclassable de mon travail
eh bien ça en rajoute encore et ça peut
aussi me paraît certes un certain chemin
alors quel est le message
quels sont les messages politiques et
philosophiques que je porte
enfin que des livres mon travail bien en
premier vous avez compris je défends
l'idée d'un art humaniste un art qui
fait passer l'humain en premier et le
partage paul ardenne par le même
d'activisme du partage alors un acte un
art humaniste oui mais dépourvu de
caractère religieux c'est à dire c'est
au sens profane c'est à dire dans dans
la mesure où chaque homme chaque femme
est responsable de son bonheur et du
chemin qu'il trace de plus en payant des
artistes professionnels et en payant des
étudiants d'écoles d'art et bien on
participe à la vie à la création d'une
économie parallèle et redistributrice
redistributrice pourquoi et bien parce
que les aides des institutions qui que
nous percevons les prestations que nous
que nous vendons est bien le tout et
intégralement redistribuée
donc dans les prés dans le salaire des
artistes etc
voilà donc c'est en ce sens là qu'on
échappe etc ont désobéi au système
actuel du marché de l'art ça c'est une
donnée aussi intéressante
d'autre part quand mon travail la
plupart du temps avec des matériaux
recyclés et avec des ressourceries eh
bien on met en oeuvre le principe des
causes ofii les causes office est quoi
et bien c'est mettre en avant l'économie
des moyens
en plus en remettant au coeur de la cité
au coeur des campagnes l'art
contemporain on participe à la lutte
contre la désertification culturel et
ans participe à la démocratisation
culturelle en même temps ses formes
voilà donc comment conclure comment
conclure 7,7 cette aventure tout en
laissant une petite porte ouverte
eh bien je vais conclure sur un travail
beaucoup plus intime mais tout aussi
audacieux parce qu'il vous avez compris
c'est l'audace ans c'est ma petite virée
en chasse aux mobiles la voilà c'est une
chasse chasse avec un accent circonflexe
sur le à la chasse est un petit coffret
religieux dans lequel est contenu soit
la dépouille d'un saint ou une sainte
ou alors des reliques et bien cette
oeuvre défend l'idée colporte l'idée que
c'est vraiment chouette de préserver les
vieilles croyances mais que c'est encore
plus important plus fondamentales et
plusieurs gens de conserver le vivant et
tous ceux qui l'entourent alors pour s'
pour faire cette oeuvre
donc j'ai utilisé la couverture de
survie la couverture de survie
j'ai utilisé un petit peu à toutes les
sauces ans pouvait savoir ça dans mon
livre alors ici c'est utilisé sous forme
de bandelettes
alors un petit peu voyez dans l'idée
comme les momies quand on conserve les
vieille momie que j'ai entouré
voilà que j'ai entouré voilà des tuyaux
pvc qui que j'avais déjà
donc utilisé pour une autre heure est
donc la couverture de survie c'est un
matériau qui m'est très cher parce que
effectivement il est déjà très chargé 1
il sert à protéger les vies bien sûr
mais il est beaucoup plus chargé encore
pour moi parce que c'est le dernier
objet que m'a transmis ma grand-mère
klorane avant qu'elle ne parte pour
faire un très grand voyage cette
couverture de survie était posé sur sa
table
elle m'a regardé et m'a dit tiens prends
ça troll à toi qui artiste tu en feras
sûrement quelque chose
alors alors maintenant c'est à mon tour
c'est à mon tour de vous dire que je
crois que vous êtes tous équipés d'une
couverture de survie dans là quelque
part donc alors pas maintenant mais plus
tard quand l'idée sera mûr et bien je
vais vous demander à votre tour de
commettre un geste artistique parce que
je sais que vous êtes capable de le
faire
et puis qui vous puisque vous avez
compris qu'il s'agissait de dons et de
contretemps et bien vous allez prendre
en photo le geste artistique que vous
allez faire et vous allez me le renvoyer
sur mon blog alors clairement encore un
auto c'est comment ne pas compliquer à
se rappeler ou alors art nomade sans eux
voilà donc j'attends vos productions et
puis sûrement après j'en ferai sûrement
autre chose à mon tour voilà merci